so you mentioned what Secretary Clinton
one of the presumptive candidates said
yesterday we've also had the other
presumptive candidate come out and say
at least two things one is we should
exclude people from Muslim countries and
from coming in because some of them have
this ideology and number two if we'd had
more people with guns in that nightclub
there wouldn't have had a tragedy what's
your reaction to that do you see how
dark it was yes the clock it's likely
that more people would have been killed
all I know is this we had a 10-year ban
on assault weapons and that was passed
when I was president I signed it we
pushed hard for it and no small number
of members of Congress lost their jobs
because they voted for that and for what
was then a comprehensive background
check law we had a 33 year low in the
gun death rate and a 46 year low in
total illegal deaths by gun homicides in
other words it worked pretty well and
then you know when it was when it was
allowed to expire for a while we didn't
seem to have an uptick in crime but if
you look at what happened with these big
weapons at Sandy Hook in Aurora Colorado
and most recently in Orlando and San
Bernardino it's it's pretty clear that
the if you're firing a lot of weapons a
lot of ammunition in a short amount of
time with an weapon it's designed only
to kill more people will die then if
you're stuck with a pistol if the guy
had just had a pistol in that nightclub
I don't think anybody believes you could
possibly kill 49 people so that's my
response